[تصفيق]
الاحتجاجات في ايران على نحو متصاعد
وانتقلت من الاحتجاج الى الاضرابات
المتسوقون وضجيجهم اختفوا من هذه الازقه
الضيقه في اسواق طهران فلا بقاله ولا جزار
ولا حتى صيدليات الا وحرصت على المشاركه
بتنفيذ قرار بدا شعبيا بامتياز
هذا المشهد متكرر في اكثر من 50 مدينه
ايرانيه اغلقت تجارها ابواب محالهم ولا
بونداء دعوات المنصقه للاضراب لمده ثلاثه
ايام
الايرانيون الذين انتقلوا من الاحتجاج
ليلا من اسطح منزلهم خوفا من قمع الحرس
الثوري يضربون في وضع النهار ويعلنون
مواقفهم بمشاركه واسعه من الطبقه العامله
من كل الفئات
جعبه النظام من التهديد واساليب القمع
التي لجا اليها لاخافه الايرانيين يبدو
انها خلت فمن قتل ميداني واحكام الاعدام
الصادره عن قضاء النظام والسجن والسحلب
بالاضافه الى التحرش باطفال باغتصاب
لفتيات كلها اعمال كشف عنها نشاطها ومراكز
حقوقيه تحت عنوان جرائم ارتكبها النظام
ونددت بها مؤسسات حقوقيه دوليه ومحليه
والان يهدد النظام لغايه تراخيص التجاريه
واعتقالي اصحابها
احتجاجات الايرانيين ضد نظام طهران تختلف
عن سابقاتها هذه المره فهي الاطول زمنا
كما تتميز بتحد يوصف بالكبير ورغم توقعات
خبراء ان تلك تظاهرات لن تسقط النظام
الحالي الا انها تشكل هزه كبيره بحقه
تنازلات ابدا نظام مرغما على تقديمها في
محاوله الاحتواء الوضع الداخلي لكن الشارع
يصفها بتنازلات مخادعه
حنان المصري العربيه